juanitis's paralysis you cease to mature
you cease to move you cease to be you
there is no the one there is no soulmate
women there is no soulmate myth there
are some good ones and some bad ones but
there is no one anyone telling you
anything else is selling you something
there are lots of special someone's out
there for you just ask the divorced and
widowed person who's remarried after
their soulmate has died or moved on yeah
if my man died I wouldn't be married you
wouldn't remarry if he died I agree with
the article no I don't man some people
might just be scared of being by
themselves man some people just don't
want to be alone man I'll tell you a
personal experience [ __ ] I've been able
to go here and
I went away whatever then
she moved on well she got back with her
childhood like sweetheart yeah boom boom
moved on relationship marriage ring on
the finger everything yeah like kids
happy home whatever
like she wants like something happens
now yeah like a bit negative like I
still get scorned upon you know what
like there's still hatred to me you know
what I get blamed no I get blamed for
going away that that situation is with
someone yeah she must have been funny
there's an argument it's your fault yeah
yeah if it's not going well it's my
fault because I should be that man you
get me like I didn't I'm trying to say
so she would like to her you were the
one yeah yeah and you were the one that
got away and it doesn't matter who she
has like yeah so although she's moved on
and she is genuinely happy that
obviously things not again happen to me
and she ain't getting out of it but she
is but so for some reason anytime my
something happens it's mindful because I
still get the like despite because you
know what if you got your act together
it should be you that you get me put
yeah
what did you say I said then she ain't
genuinely no she's genuinely happy it
goes back to people it goes back to
there's relativeness to the happiness
because if say like I wasn't one of her
body counts now
totally happy in that situation she
feels like she's settled yeah
do you guys think that's common among
women
what exactly is the question so that
said you were you listening when he said
do you think that's a common situation
where the girl is with a new guy but she
misses the old guy
I feel like that can happen if if you
have an ex and you've been with for a
certain amount of years or whatever and
then you're with a new guy and then he's
not making you feel like had other guys
feeling because you had time to do that
because you're doing for eight years so
the guy in this one month ain't sure I
knew that you might be thinking raw I
can't feel like this but times take time
things take time to know
um
I don't think it's that common because I
feel like if a woman if a woman is truly
truly satisfied with her new partner
her ex ain't even gonna come across her
her
um mind because the new guy is bringing
more to if she's saying she's genuinely
happiest because the new guy is bringing
something different he's bringing
something more he is doing things that
her crusty X obviously wasn't doing so
the fact that she [ __ ] up why is it
crusty amazing maybe she [ __ ] up well
well yeah okay maybe she [ __ ] up but
I'm saying like if if she just like not
obviously on about you but generally if
if the woman is generally happy with
their next part and I don't think it's
that common because I think when when I
personally think like you know when they
say like when a man cheats like or if a
woman cheats on a guy and he's
heartbroken and this and that it's like
it's very concrete for them but like
when a woman will forgive a guy cheating
a lot but when she's done she's done and
I think that's why it can't be common
because I feel like when a woman is done
with a guy she's done with a guy but but
what I found is there's always the one
that got away and I think that's why
that's why I brought up that song that
was all over the rainbow I'm sure if I
played it you guys would hear it like
yeah yeah and I'm saying I think that
resonates with women because there's
there's not I think women move on faster
than men and you're right when she's
done she's done but I I do think there's
this concept of girls having The One
That Got Away go ahead I think it's if
you it's about whether you healed or not
I think yeah you can move on but if you
haven't healed then that will always be
the one you got away but once you truly
deal with the trauma you have from that
past situationship relationship that's
when you can
move on so I'm curious when you guys
hear healing as men what does that say
to you that like I had to heal that a
man put a man put you through no no no I
want to hear from them what is what is
that that mean run run why because men
ain't no purpose no but he said they
have to heal with you no there's no
eating you have not eat you think you
have and as soon as men do something oh
my accident that's how you probably move
I'm going but that's just a human thing
to happen
Okay I wanna I wanna let the guys talk
really quick I want to hear from the
guys when you hear that what is that
scripture so you say run yeah why though
like why do I need your [ __ ] from
your previous relationship why not
bringing my [ __ ] when does a man
bring his [ __ ] to this
relationships no a man don't do that
it's always you girl want to bring
Bayesian to man I'm blaming for what
Gary done forgotten John Peter Paul and
all the members in the Bible
so what about you when you hear that
what do you hear I just said instability
so it's like I might lie down with you a
couple times I'm not gonna take it so
you're ready okay what about you yeah do
you know what like when you hear healing
healing needs to be like I had to heal
healing should be done by yourself like
you can't come with me and be healing
but women hardly ever do that so when a
girl heals they go to the club yeah
that's what that's what their friends
cast them up their friends girl you need
to come out man
it's good and come on I've just heard
from guys when they hear healing it
means run through yeah
my brain likes you anyway man I was
supposed to tell you before my pregnant
the biggest problem in that relationship
is not your girl you know it's your girl
crusty friend that's got no man got no
man got no man we run through a bag of
time don't know to keep a relationship
because her attitudes stink and she just
hate men from from birth and it's
telling you a girl no forget about him
and then when you leave your Gala get
his accent that's in life but men bring
their baggage as well when they got them
dramatic crazy baby moms or Nah serious
you just got some bad experience
[Music]
if you pick someone you cannot be mad if
you and I say the same thing to them if
you pick someone that has a child that's
baggage
like it also is okay it's contrary to
that point as well when men are overly
controlling with next women I think
that's Trauma from their past
relationships like if they've been
cheated on what's controlling to you
what's controlling to me um a guy trying
to tell me what I kind of cannot wear
where I can and kind of man tells me
that really yeah yeah I don't know
when I come on the podcast I mustn't
show my knees because otherwise I must
be careful than what I wear because when
I step out the house I representing him
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible